là où ça bouge je descends dans la
piscine de coutances où elle est bonne
très très bonne viande est bonne il n'y
a pas d'eau pour faire le tour jacques
au liban tall une chute dans le chaînage
et voici mesdames et messieurs le groupe
delson qui a donc décidé de jouer ce
soir à coutances au fond d'une piscine
on a profité du nid d'ange pour se dire
on va faire une animation alors à la
complexité c'est qu'effectivement lundi
y avait de l'eau est il que mercredi on
remet en eau donc on a juste en gros 48
heures pour monter démonter entre deux
fins faire un concert donc il fallait
trouver quand même des musiciens qui
étaient un peu burlesque qui savait
faire tout avec eux rien ce soit vous
allez faire combien de temps elle m'a et
remplissent la piscine à 21h45 je crois
d'accord je sais pas c'est quoi je sais
pas comment
je sais pas pourquoi je sais pas ce
qu'ils sont bordéliques alors ils font
de la musique avec avec tout ce qu'ils
trouvent et vous les accompagnez en
vidéo et au gré de leur fantaisie
il ya un esprit très enfantin dans tout
ça mais très sérieux voilà c'est ça
mélange de burlesque et en plus de
personnages qui sont très complexes mais
très appliqué
c'est un peu con et réciproquement
c'est pourquoi
et puis pour terminer sachez que je dis
aux portobello à quand il ira grande
soirée rock avec le groupe
ryall qui ce qui vient des états unis ce
sera en même temps qu beauregard les
insu évidemment mais comme ce concert de
beauregard est complet ça vous permet de
voir quand même du rock'n'roll de
walkinshaw portobello jeudi soir
le thème
lyon